squid game is the new south korean
thriller that's been tearing up netflix
since it premiered on september 17 2021.
over its nine episode first season squid
game offers up a uniquely violent
premise that is equal parts the hunger
games the purge and the 2014 japanese
thriller as the god's will but squid
game isn't just a 10 hour shock fest it
also has something to say about the
world we live in
we gotta keep an eye out
it'll be dangerous
lee jong-jae stars as song gi hun a man
who is down on his luck in nearly every
way then one day a mysterious stranger
offers him an opportunity the chance to
compete against 455 other desperate
people for a life-changing amount of
money unfortunately it turns out the
competition in question is a series of
sadistic children's games in which
contestants are forced to compete to the
death as gihan fights to survive he
discovers more about both the contest
itself and what he may be capable of as
a person in the final episode of squid
game's first season gehan does win the
contest but it's about as hollow as a
victory can get here's what the ending
of squid game season 1 is all about
let me explain the rules of squid game
the competition comes down to two
contestants gihan and his childhood best
friend cho seong-woo the final
competition starts off with a coin flip
which is a symbolic representation of
who these men are gihan is the guy who
tried to do everything right in life he
worked hard played by the rules believed
in the system and still ended up nearly
destitute song woo on the other hand is
the guy who took shortcuts to get ahead
before the games he was a wanted
criminal who embezzled from his clients
just like the coin flip that starts the
game all their choices were illusory
because both men wound up in the same
place they're just two sides of the same
coin as the game plays out gihan defeats
songwoo but he also comes to see how
rigged the game really is he refuses to
kill his former pal and by offering
mercy he rebels against the game but
this is a futile gesture because seong
wu takes his own life in order to hand
the win to gi hun gihan wins but by this
point he's already lost everything that
matters the show picks up one year after
giuhan's victory his life isn't much
different yes he has the money but while
he was away competing his mother died
and his ex-wife took his daughter to los
angeles and as a result of everything
that has happened gihan has all but
given up on life to make matters worse
there's still one more gut punch for
gihan to endure after the time jump
gihan gets an invitation from player 1
whom he befriended during the contest
not only is player 1 still alive he also
reveals himself to be the mastermind of
the games after being diagnosed with a
terminal illness player one created the
deadly games for his own amusement and
that of his friends
you put us through all of that
so you can have fun
gihan is enraged to learn that the rich
and powerful treated him and 454 other
people like playthings he's even more
outraged when player 1 tells him that he
believes people are fundamentally
selfish player 1 and gihan notice a
dying homeless man out the window of
their hospital and to prove his point
player 1 bets gihan that nobody will
help when people do help gihan undergoes
a transformation having witnessed the
kindness of strangers firsthand gihan
knows what he has to do stop the games
from continuing player 1 has already
been proven wrong all that's left to do
is undo the terrible contest he's
created the colors red and green are
important throughout the series the
first game in the contest is the korean
version of red light green light
everyone organizing the contest wears
red while everyone competing wears green
red and green symbolize power and
powerlessness respectively after the
time jump when gihan learns that the
people running the contest are just
bored rich folks who created it for
their own amusement he undergoes a
literal transformation by dying his hair
red gihan has moved over to the ranks of
the powerful and unlike the contest
organizers he uses his new wealth for
good by helping the family members of
several other contestants however gihan
can only do so much to his horror he
learns that the games are still
happening season one ends with a
red-haired gihan making a threatening
phone call to the contest organizers
vowing to bring them all down is he an
avenging symbol of the underclass yes
but not everything is quite so inspiring
when gihan heads off to continue his
work he also walks away from a flight to
la that would have taken him to see his
daughter if squid game does return for a
second season gihan might become an
avenger of the powerless but he also
might lose whatever shreds of humanity
he has left
[Music]
this game is over
yep that about wraps it up check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]